hi amanda linney with people
congratulations you look thanks stunning
i mean do you just stand up here and
think about how much you have evolved in
your career how far you've gone what
does this mean to you
on top of everything else you've done uh
oh um
yeah it's
so
shocking in a way because i you know i
don't have expectations
and i don't want for things like
recognition
even though like because i feel like
i've trained myself not to from a young
age but i'm also evolving as a human
being and understanding that it's okay
to feel pride when you work really hard
and also when you
i don't know have an incredible
experience i also know i'm privileged to
be able to do what i love and then get
opportunities like this
i know i i i yeah i'm i don't know if i
would have been able to take it in
this way in such a healthy way if i was
younger
but i feel like i have enough pride to
feel like this is real and i can believe
it even though it's crazy but it's like
i appreciate it in a way that i never
would have
if i didn't if i wasn't at this point in
my career it's like the opportunities
this opportunity was incredible
so many people wanted to do it i got to
do it and i knew that i needed to work
my ass off
and also liz merryweather like i
wouldn't be here without her
good writers good directors
um
liz with today's show um how long did it
take you to kind of
you know get out of your persona of
elizabeth and just kind of shake her off
actually not as long as i thought
because i was so over her
by the end of the show because i had you
know you have to come in with a you have
to delude yourself to a point as an as
an actor
um this i had to deliver myself more
than normal because i'm playing somebody
i don't necessarily agree with but i
have to have as much compassion for her
as anybody
in order to embody this person and oh
wow look at all those people
um
[Music]
it was
but i think i had just been done i'd
never played somebody that long
for the four and a half months of my
life every single day i gave it all
to this job
and i was just done if the trial was
happening i was just like i gotta throw
her away so i didn't do the voice for
like two months until my doorman was
like can you do the voice
and i was like sure dave i'll do the
voice
only for you
the next question comes virtually from
ahad with hello
magazine
hi amanda this is a hunt from hello
congratulations on your win thanks
uh you mentioned your kids in your
speech how do you think how do they
react when you win these awards and how
do you think they're going to react to
your annual tonight um
it's my first
uh
and i mean i've been honored with things
but this is like an award show that's so
massive and
um they got to watch it on tv so my
daughter actually cried because she was
confused
about how i spoke to her
through the tv and i was like
are you kidding
me and so i called her she was supposed
to be in bed she's going to school
tomorrow she was just i don't know i
didn't expect that to be the reaction
uh but i think in 10 years she'll
appreciate it but um yeah i don't know
about my son he's too young to know
anything really
um but
i i i really wanted to do that for them
and i my husband was like you gotta just
talk to them when you when you get up
there
if you get up there you just gotta talk
to them because
those are the people that matter and
this is what you're doing you know this
is what you're doing it all for now so
it's good interesting i'm gonna i gotta
have a conversation with her when i get
home
congratulations again thanks thank you
hi amanda alex with parade i'm just
curious how how do you learn to dance
completely without rhythm
got to be born with it
um oh you know what's funny elizabeth
holmes and i both were on the dance team
in our high schools
which i found out very early on in my
preparation and my research and i found
that really astounding because it's very
rare that you meet someone that was in
the dance team
and from who i spoke to apparently she
was not great and i was also in the
third row which is where they put you
when you're not that great so the fact
that we both
have that in our pasts and the fact that
i've seen her dance
in a way that's
unlike a good dancer
i knew that i could that was one of the
things that really made me feel
connected to her i know that sounds
crazy but um that was one of the most
fun parts about it like oh i have an in
there
she's
not super skilled at that as as i
also am not super skilled at
our next question comes virtually from
shirlena with spoiler tv
hi hi
congratulations on your own win thanks
now to portray a unique character how do
you adapt to the role and get into the
character's mindset when portraying a
real one
well like
yeah when you portray a character at a
role okay yeah just
mindset yeah you gotta know i mean
here's the thing when i'm playing
someone who's real which i've only done
three times i i i have something to
actually hold on to i have something
real and factual
whereas with a character that i don't
know that we're making up completely i
have to like make something up so in
some ways this is easier in that respect
than playing someone i don't know
so i'm usually i usually end up playing
myself so when i'm preparing to play
myself
i have to picture myself in the
situations and circumstances that the
character's in and that can actually
sometimes be more of a
than playing somebody real
i don't know it's hard sometimes it's
easier than other times but it's like if
a character is doing something in their
life that they're passionate about i
have to then try to
find a passion for what they're doing
for a time
and that takes that's fun
it's like a good
fun part
you